foreign
hello and hello everyone I think we need
to start with the question that some of
them may have seen on their screen
already what is fun you might think that
we all know what fun is but I found it
really interesting in my research to
realize that the way we use fun in our
everyday speech which at least in
English is very casual we kind of toss
around this word it's really different
from the feeling you get from people if
you ask them about a memory from their
own lives in which they had the most fun
um and as part of the research for my
book I did that I asked people from all
around the world they see we have a ton
of people from all around the world even
in this webinar so the answers I got
were very International and it was
really interesting because even though
obviously people's individual
experiences were different there was
this energy running through them that
was very much the same and when I read
through these answers and I've got
thousands of these by now I found myself
smiling but also almost tearing up a lot
of times there's something really
powerful about what people were sharing
with me they went Way Beyond this
light-hearted pleasure sense with which
we often use the word so I ended up
coming up with a definition based on
these stories people were sharing with
me and then running it by them to see if
it accurately described what they had
told me so I tried to validate it and it
is that when we have these moments of
what I think of as true fun it's the
Confluence of three states and those are
playfulness connection and flow and so
if you think of a Venn diagram with
three circles in the center you have
true fun and you have playfulness
connection and flow and just to clarify
because people can you know freak out in
particular about playfulness adults
really get uncomfortable with
playfulness it means just having a
lighthearted attitude you can just be
light-hearted not care too much about
the outcome of what you're doing let go
of your perfectionism
connection refers to having a special
shared experience and I do think some
people can have fun on their own as I
say in my TED talk but it was really
interesting because most of the stories
people told me involved other people and
when I ask people what surprised you
about what you just told me a number of
people said something along the lines of
I'm an introvert but everything I just
told you involved other people
so in the majority of situations another
person is involved and then flow is the
psychological state where we get so
wrapped up in what we're doing actively
engaged in what we're doing that we can
lose track of time so an athlete playing
a game is the most quintessential
example all three of those days are
great on their own but I believe when
you experience all three at once that's
what I call true fun so to the adult
question of why we lose playfulness well
I I think some of it is because fun can
seem maybe frivolous in the in a very
serious world and and the world is quite
serious but uh why is it important to
have fun thanks for asking that question
David because that is a common
misperception people have about fun is
that it is frivolous or that you know
there's so many serious things going on
in the world how can we possibly think
about fun so a couple of things I would
say to that first of all life is not
zero-sum so I don't see why you can't be
someone who cares about the serious
issues in the world and also cares about
fun and also a lot of what we do when we
say we're caring about serious issues is
really kind of meaningless and just
torturing ourselves if you read the same
news article that makes you upset six
times in an hour you haven't actually
helped anybody and the same thing if
you've posted a rant on social media or
gotten an argument or just worked
yourself up or essentially yelled at
someone on Twitter that didn't actually
help anybody and it's very draining so
what I find about fun is that when we
actually have fun my point being here is
that fun can actually help us work to
solve some of those problems and the
reason I say that is that first of all
when you have enough fun yourself it
actually fills up your own reserves it
builds your resilience and your energy
and that will give you the energy to do
something more productive than just yell
at people via your phone's social media
you know accounts but then also if you
actually have fun with other people and
you've connected with them as human
beings so if we're able to have fun with
each other we can connect in a way that
then helps us work together to actually
solve some of those problems and then I
would also say fun isn't frivolous even
if the world was great and there weren't
any problems fun itself is not frivolous
because fun and I'm happy to go into
more detail if anyone wants more detail
but is actually really important not
just for our mental health but also for
our physical health because of the way
it reduces our stress levels and also
provides us with a sense of social
connection
yeah fun is is good for your health I
think that's uh the important thing to
remember but but as you pointed out we
shouldn't get too wrapped up uh maybe an
anxiety about whether we're having
whether we're having enough fun you also
talk about something called fake fun
what's what's that so fake fun is a term
I came up with to describe products and
services that are marketed to us as fun
but that aren't actually fun in the
sense that they don't actually produce
playfulness connection or flow
the biggest culprit here is definitely
social media and kind of these or you
know watching passive consumption past
the point of enjoyment so if you're
watching your favorite show for a couple
episodes great but if you're like in
that zone where you're actually
completely hypnotized and it's seven
hours have passed and you feel
disgusting about yourself and your life
you've fallen into the Trap of fake fun
so I see it as there being actually
three categories you've got true fun the
playful connected flow you've got fake
fun which is essentially the junk food
of our Leisure Time that ends us it's
very appealing but it leaves us feeling
disgusting about ourselves there's a big
middle category of stuff that's truly
enjoyable but that wouldn't necessarily
qualify as true Fun by the definition of
proposed and that would be things like
reading you know or like taking a bath
or watching your favorite TV show up to
the point where it's still enjoyable to
me those are all legitimate great uses
of your leisure time even if they're not
fun because you know you actually enjoy
them and the reason I think it's
important to divide I mean to think so
intellectually about fun is that it
helps us become much more intentional
about how we use our leisure time so if
you're able to identify sources of fake
fun in your life it's actually really
easy to eliminate those once you've kind
of cognitively recognize that that you
know it's a waste of time and if you're
like oh yeah this is actually enjoyable
go for it and then if it's likely to
generate true fun I would suggest
putting it on the top of your priority
list because it's such a wonderfully
nourishing State Ted member Don and
Stefania are you know feel slightly
overwhelmed uh by their lives and have
trouble even thinking of what fun feels
like if you've forgotten what fun feels
like how do you how do you find it again
one of the things I recommend people do
to start is to think back on a moment of
true fun from your own life a moment
that you describe as quote so fun that
was the term I came up with when I was
asking people this question don't worry
it can actually take a little bit of
time to tune in to those experiences but
I can assure you we've all had them they
don't need to be dramatic it's not this
is another misconception we have about
fun that it only can happen in exotic
low cows or when you're somehow outside
of your quote normal life or that it
costs a lot of money none of that is
true if you define it as playful
connected flow you'll start to recognize
that you can have even tiny moments of
fun
all the time and the reason you want to
call to mind one of these experiences is
that as you begin to think of more of
them so I encourage you to try to think
of more than one and it will become
easier as you start thinking of them to
call out some themes and see huh are
there any particular people who are
often involved are there any activities
that are involved are there any settings
that seem conducive to fun because if
you've seen my TED talk you know that I
believe that fun is a feeling and it's
not an activity by which I mean that I
think too often we start to think like
if I ask you guys what's fun just at the
beginning of this conversation you might
start to give me a list of activities
that you enjoy and say cooking's fun or
reading's fun or whatever but the
activity itself is not fun it's the
feeling of fun like you can love dinner
parties and have
the exact same group of people over for
dinner and eat the exact same thing and
one night it's gonna be really fun and
one night it's not gonna be fun so it's
the feeling that results so the point of
calling out these settings and these
people in these activities that are
often associated with fun for you is not
to guarantee that you can have fun if
you're with them but to set the scene
for it to make it more likely that fun
will occur and result I think about it
like romance like you can set the scene
forward but if you try too hard it's
gonna run away right so we're trying to
light candles for fun but I I call the
settings and the people and the
activities are fun magnets and each of
us has a collection that is unique to us
you know my husband's fun magnets are
not necessarily the same as mine we have
some that we share we have some that are
different and the point is just to
become more cognizant of what those
things are so again you can become more
intentional about how you choose to
spend your leisure time
um I also created a whole acronym in the
book and like a framework that's called
spark which I'm happy to go through but
I'll just end up talking straight for
half an hour if I go down that route so
David you can choose but I'd start with
that try to identify past members of fun
call out or look for themes and then
prioritize those people and activities
and settings
well let's talk about spark a little bit
because in looking through the chat I
mean that's why we asked for the moments
of delight it's a a moment for people to
reflect and think about something that
was probably pretty fun if it delighted
you it was probably pretty fun
um so tell us a little bit more about uh
the importance of noticing and this
whole spark method so the first step in
spark the S actually stands for make
space because we do need to clear out
some space for fun if you're feeling
constantly overwhelmed you're probably
gonna feel like you can't even begin
this process
what I recommend that people start with
in terms of clearing space is to begin
with the biggest source of distraction
for most of us these days which is our
phones and our digital devices
before the pandemic the average person
was spending in America was spending
upwards of four hours a day just on
their phones so not their tablets not
their computers not their TVs just their
phones which is a quarter of your Waking
Life and it adds up to 60 full days a
year when you think about it that way
like sure some of that time is useful
and productive and perhaps essential but
there's also a lot of it that's just a
kind of fruit or in a way of time the
fake fun that we're talking about and if
you're able to create better boundaries
with your devices and what more of what
I call screen life balance you're going
to end up with more free time that you
then can devote towards pursuing fun so
another way to create space is actually
to think about your commitments and see
which ones you could say no to like for
example I used to volunteer on my
daughter's preschool board and then at
some point I'm like the school's fine
I'm not adding to it and I'm not
enjoying the meetings and so I quit and
it cleared up a lot of space also giving
yourself a permission slip is huge in
terms of making space a lot of people
think that they don't deserve fun that
they there are too many other priorities
they're taking care of other people
their needs are at the bottom of the
list so I've actually had people say
that they have written out a actual
permission slip for themselves and sign
in so if that's your deal like do it I
think it's actually really important
whether it's a literal permission slip
or a mental one then the p is to pursue
passions and hobbies and interests the
more interests you have and the more
skills and knowledge you have the more
interest in your life will be first of
all but also the more portals into
playful connected flow you'll find and
the thing that sparked that idea for me
was the book flow by mahali chicksemihai
who's this was the psychologist who
coined the term flow and in his book he
made this comment that really stood out
to me which was that to someone who
doesn't play chess a chess board is just
a board with some carved figurines
honestly that's what it still is to me
but if you know how to play chess if you
put in the work to learn to play chess
it becomes a portal into flow and I
would argue into fun but the idea is
just get out there try something new do
something new get up off your couch you
know it might take a bit to get over
your inertia at first but it is worth it
so that's the p is the pursue passions
the AF spark is for attract fun because
you probably have noticed there's
certain people in your life who just
seem to have more fun than you and you
might not know why you might think it's
you have fun two days this guy just look
at him having lots of fun
um but when I ask people in my research
I straight up ask them describe someone
in your life whom you consider a quote
fun person and then tell me like what
about them makes them fun and even I
thought that that'd get a lot of really
stereotypical responses they're
extroverts or the the lives of the party
or their clown you know the class clowns
there were some of those but it was so
interesting because a lot of people said
things like um they make everyone feel
very comfortable in their presence or
they laugh very easily at other people's
jokes or stories or they go along with
things you know they go with the flow
and it really stood out to me because
the traits they were describing were not
necessarily associated with extroversion
so you can be an introvert and make
someone feel comfortable I think in some
cases introverts are better at tuning
into that and also a lot of them were
trainable you can get better at those
skills so I got really interested in the
idea of how do we become people who
attract more fun and I think what I just
described are three ways to do so
another is to switch yourself into what
I think of as a fun mindset which is a
fun oriented Twist on Carol dweck's
growth mindset and the idea there is
that our default mode our brain's
default mode is naturally going to be to
focus on things that cause us anxiety
and fear for the simple reason that
that's evolutionarily how we avoid
threats you want to be scanning The
Horizon for threats otherwise you could
get killed or eaten or something so it
actually takes work to switch yourself
to focus on the positive and I think
that the more you do so the more likely
you are to notice the moments of playful
connected flow and to create more
opportunities for it so if you can start
to begin to to deliberately pay more
attention to the Delight in the world
instead of going with the natural
tendency to focus on sources of anxiety
and fear it really will get you into a
mindset that's much more conducive
the r in spark may be my favorite it is
for rebel
[Laughter]
I love him jail Rebellion to clarify but
when I was reading through people's
anecdotes there was this repeated theme
of the playful deviance is what I'll
call it of breaking the rules just like
a little bit you know I mean skinny
dipping would be an example of that but
even someone who said that they had
snuck into a pool with um you know at
night I think fully clothes with like a
laundry basket and some pool noodles
I don't know and like they'd had a great
time or really anything like if you
normally listen to educational podcasts
maybe you can drive around in your car
and turn off the podcasts and the news
and just like blast a song you love when
you were 17 and sing along and you know
or just take a little break from your
work day to do something that will bring
you a sense of delight so rebellion and
if you can't think of a way to do that I
think it's also kind of fun to think
about ways to do something delightful
for somebody else a way to do something
that's going to surprise them so maybe
this is a little bit separate but I find
that that can be a way if you're still
thinking I can't think of something to
do in my own life do something to
Delight someone else and then lastly the
K of spark is keep at it which basically
means that you know fun is much like
exercise like you're not gonna do it
once and then that's it you're done you
actually have to keep prioritizing it
because life is gonna keep throwing like
not fun things your way and unless
you're working to keep that as a
priority you're just you're not gonna
it's not going to be a priority and the
way that I personally think about
approaching that is in terms of what I
call Micro Doses and then booster shots
so if you know that there's something
small a little micro dose that you could
work into your schedule regularly that
you enjoy that might lead to clinical
connected flow like a regular coffee
date or a walk with a friend who you've
realized is a fun magnet for you or in
my case like my weekly guitar class is
definitely regular microdoses fill that
into your schedule you know carve out
the time for it and then a booster shot
would be something that takes more time
more energy maybe more money although
again fun doesn't necessarily require
money but you know if you know that you
when every time you get together with
this particular group of friends it's
just outrageously fun then like actually
go to the work of organizing and
figuring out how to get child care and
whatever so you can spend time with them
and I think that if you can sprinkle
these micro Doses and booster shots into
your life regularly you will build the
framework
for a life that is conducive to fun
uh so one of the things that I found fun
in your book is that you uh called for a
fun audit which you thought that sounds
fun David I think that sounds incredibly
unfun this is speaking well I'm saying
it sounds like an oxymoron right but
actually a fun audit can be a good thing
to do if you're feeling stuck so tell us
about a fun audit the fun audit involves
looking reviewing your own life and just
noticing how much fun you are or are not
having scanning through your leisure
activities and identifying those sources
of fake fun that we're talking about so
that you can begin to reduce or
eliminate them and then very importantly
figuring out some activities or
something to do to replace the time that
you were spending on the time sucking
um fake fun but I you know it is a
struggle for some folks and yeah wants
to know how we can create fun while
grappling with you know things like
climate change or nuclear war or all the
other you know frankly existential
threats that are out there in the world
I think it's really important I think a
lot of people feel that way and then we
do get consumed and the media landscape
is designed to make us feel that way
that's another thing to acknowledge is
that not only are our brains naturally
primed to notice those things but
you know there's an expression in
journalism if it bleeds it leads like
the you never open up your favorite
newspaper and see an article about how
there's a real you know
explosion in puppies like there's
nothing that doesn't happen so I think
also being more judicious about what you
allow into your brain because I mean
anytime you pick up your phone I think
of it as a Pandora's box of emotions
it's going to result in an emotion what
emotion is that going to be and do you
want that in your brain right if you
check the news it's going to have an
impact on your mental state if you check
your email if you check social media
I'm not saying I know what that reaction
is going to be for you but there is
going to be one so as an example I used
to have the news app on my phone and I
would find myself reading the same
articles again and again hoping
something would have changed which it
didn't then I always realized I'm not
going to have the news app on my phone
think about notifications as
interruptions because that's really what
they're doing and then I would suggest
asking yourself what you want to be
interrupted for because notifications
are there for the benefit of the people
making the app that sent you the
notification it's not for you and I
think that many of us feel very very
trapped in this feeling that the world
is dark and horrible and that we're
powerless
and that's a horrible place to be and I
think it takes a lot of work to bring
yourself out of that but it's worth it
and it actually is good for trying to
address some of those things
I think fun is probably best shared uh
as you noted earlier any tips on how to
share fun with uh with the folks in our
lives I think Jim wanted to know that
well I think picking the right people is
there's certain
people really are not conducive to fun
and hopefully you can help them to
change right but as a first step if you
know if you're the choice between
hanging out with someone who
consistently is makes you feel
comfortable and you enjoy being in the
presence of and generates fun versus
someone as a wet blanket just pick that
one right
um again I talked about doing things
together I think that things like
cooking a meal together or trying
something new together or seeing if your
friends want to go to a class together
or you know all those things are very
conducive to
um opening people up in a way that helps
people have fun I think also trying to
find people who are already having fun
and joining that group uh I want to
thank all the members for coming I also
want to apologize for not getting to all
of your questions but the time just kind
of flew by because you know we were
having fun uh so thank you thank you
very much for joining us today and uh go
have some fun
thanks David you too
[Music]